lors de la chirurgie de chirurgie
retirer ce qu'on voit sur la résonance
magnétique sans nécessairement aller au
delà ses marges
mais la réalité avec le cancer du
cerveau c'est que ce sont les cellules
qui sont au-delà du conte de caste de
résonance magnétique qui sont importants
ce sont ces cellules là qui vont être la
cause de récidive
ce qu'on voit ici en fait c'est en
arrière-plan c'est un cerveau
qui est obtenu à la d'une image de
résonance magnétique ce qu'on a fait ici
c'est que ce qui est coloré le le rouge
l'orangé le jaune s'est enfin rendu qui
nous donne ce que la résonance
magnétique croit être la cuma si vous
voulez ok donc à partir de ce moment si
si si on regarde les différents points
ici ce sont des points où nous on a fait
des mesures de spectroscopie raman
durant la chirurgie ces points-là ici
étaient tous cancéreux hockey tels que
prédit par la spectroscopie raman
cependant ces points là sont bien au
delà des marges de la tumeur telles que
trouver par la résonance magnétique donc
de 1.5 à 2 centimètres plus loin que les
marges étaient par la résonance
magnétique qui est en fait le star
l'heure actuelle pour là pour guider la
neurochirurgie c'est un outil qui est
tenu par le chirurgien dans sa main donc
c'est comme un saint
caillaud le surge ils l'utilisent comme
il utilise un outil chirurgicale
conventionnel la mesure se prend en
temps réel point deux secondes donc
c'est très rapide ça augmente
l'efficacité on va tirer de détecter
plus de plus grand plus grand volume
tumoral durant la chirurgie puis aussi
ça va nous assurer sa va sur un
chirurgien que lorsqu'il est en train de
retirer du sud n'est pas en train de
retirer des tissus normaux donc renoué
pour minimiser en fait comment on va
affecter les fonctions cognitives et
motrices du patient suite à la chirurgie